[Musik]
Frühlingsrollen sind lecker schnell
serviert und extrem lukrativ und das ist
alles am Füllung dahinter steckt eine
weltweite Lebensmittelindustrie
Sebastian deckt auf was drin steckt er
serviert vorgefertigte Frühlingsrollen
und billigste Krabbenchips
was darf beim asiatischen Gericht auch
nicht fehlen und ist noch günstiger wie
so eine kleine Frühlingsrolle
Kollege krabbenchip haben Sie schon mal
überlegt wie die gemacht werden
echtes Krabbenfleisch steckt nicht drin
nur etwas krabbenschale maximal so viel
weil es soll ja auch nur Aroma geben und
sehen Sie
da kann man so ganz ganz ganz kleine
Stützen erkennen das formalen Schale der
Rest ist
Stärke Glutamat Salz Gewürze fertig
Krabbenchips werden als Rohlinge
verkauft die wirft Sebastian da nur kurz
in die Friteuse
in der Stärke steckt noch etwas
Feuchtigkeit die verdampft im heißen Öl
und bläst die krabbenchiprohlinge auf
dadurch werden sie mehr als doppelt so
groß
das ist mal Volumen oder so
paar Krabbenchips gefällig
und das war noch nicht mal ein Viertel
aus der Tüte ich kann den ganzen Laden
hier mit Krabbenchips voll machen
ein Produkt das sich für Restaurants
rechnet denn ein einzelner rote kostet
nur 3,7 Cent eine Hand voll davon landet
ausgebacken beim Gast für
durchschnittlich 2,50 €. macht trotz
teurem Öl eine sagenhafte Marge von 500%
geniale Erfindung oder mit ein bisschen
Stärke ein Hauch von Garnele ein paar
Gewürzen
erschaffe ich so viel Material und wir
denken boah das ist ja mal großzügig so
eine große Tüte
Sebastian lege möchte seinen Gästen
außerdem Frühlingsrollen servieren ein
aufwendiges Produkt
ein kleiner Snack und so viele Zutaten
haben sie nicht gedacht doch mein
schnell reingebissen knusprige Hülle
knackiges Gemüse kennen wir alle die
Frühlingsrolle
[Musik]
Sebastian leege baut sie nach aus Wasser
Weizenmehl Salz Milcheiweiß und Stärke
dazu noch die Zusatzstoffe Maltodextrin
und Ascorbinsäure
[Musik]
und Tropfen Öl
das Öl ist ganz wichtig damit der Teig
nicht austrocknet und seine Elastizität
behält wir wollen ja eine Rolle machen
der perfekte Teig für eine
Frühlingsrolle soll beim Wickeln nicht
aufreißen und durch das Frittieren schön
krost werden
[Musik]
gerade wenn so kracht im Mund dass du
dieser chipseffekt
die Raupe Nimmersatt
so hier Sebastian lege setzt auf ein
crepeisen aus der französischen Küche es
nimmt den Teig hauchdünn auf
nee ist kein Tischtennisschläger
gebe ich hier rein
[Musik]
müssen wir noch mal üben aus ganz
günstigen Zutaten backt der
Produktentwickler viele dünne Fladen die
perfekte Hülle für eine Frühlingsrolle
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir es doch hier
abtropfen für die Füllung setzt er auf
saisonal günstiges Gemüse und ein
Zaubermittel Sojasprossen Bambus
Möhren
Pilze
Zuckerschoten
glutamatisch
eigentlich Mono Natrium glutamat wird in
der günstigen asiatischen Küche oft als
chemisch hergestelltes Pulver zugesetzt
geschmacksneutrale Glasnudeln werden
getrocknet verkauft sie bestehen aus
Stärke und müssen nur kurz mit heißem
Wasser aufgegossen werden und jetzt
Glasnudeln klar noch nicht Stärke
Komponente so brauche ich von dem teuren
Gemüse oder weniger und kann damit schön
auffüllen
viel Teig und dazu noch Nudeln so
reduziert die Industrie das
vergleichsweise teure Gemüse zusätzlich
saugen die Glasnudeln das Wasser der
Gemüsefüllung auf und sorgen für einen
saftigen Biss und fertig ist die Füllung
jetzt
[Musik]
bist du nur zusammenbauen
das Einrollen per Hand braucht etwas
Geschick wenig Füllung viel außen herum
das ist der Teig
trinke meine Frühlingsrolle
jetzt passen sie mal auf
ich glaube den Teig einmal um ich
schlage ihn an den Seiten ein dann mache
ich ein bisschen nass
und dann wickle ich ihn ganz stramm ein
eine Frühlingsrolle besteht aus bis zu
vier Lagen Teig der ist günstig und
frittiert knusperte wie eine Portion
Chips
schön
herrlich guck mal also richtig schöne
kleine Blubberbläschen wenn sie
aufreißen sind kaputt aber die halten
sogar noch so sind doppelt gewickelt
viel Teig wenig Unfälle
[Gelächter]
auffallend diese Rollen sind viel größer
und dicker als die im Asia Restaurant
lecker
hinter den allermeisten
Mini-Frühlingsrollen steckt in
Wirklichkeit eine mega-industrie
entfernt Ost Stellen Fabriken die
Tiefkühlprodukte für die ganze Welt her
genormt und immer gleich
tatsächlich wird bis heute per Hand
gerollt zu niedrigsten Löhnen
Sebastian lege besucht einen deutschen
Großhandel für asia-restaurants
hier gibt es die tiefgekühlten
Frühlingsrollen küchenfertig direkt vom
Hersteller
asiatische Großmärkte und der deutsche
Gigant Metro verkaufen die
standardisierte Tiefkühlware im XXL
Karton handgerollt aus China
Zielgruppe für die günstige tiefkühlbare
sind Asia Restaurants und Schnellimbisse
Sebastian lege macht die Stichprobe und
kauft Frühlingsrollen bei 10
verschiedenen Asia Restaurants wer rollt
selber wer setzt auf Fertigware schauen
wir mal wie lang also hier die sind
jetzt bei 5,5
auch 5,5
ja doch 5,5 also Länge überall gleich
und das Gewicht
16 Gramm
15 Gramm das Gewicht unterscheidet sich
minimal denn die Rollen saugen in der
Friteuse unterschiedlich viel Öl auf
vieles spricht dafür dass hier
tiefgekühltes aus Fernost verkauft wurde
[Musik]
10 von 10 Frühlingsrollen aus dem Asia
Restaurant sind äußerlich praktisch
identisch dann
schneide ich mal eine auf
der Inhalt überrascht selbst Sebastian
lege
und das ist alles am Füllung
reisnudelkohl Möhre Zwiebel fein
gehäckselt also
Rolle Füllung
die Hersteller haben erkannt dass sie
hier richtig viel billigen Teig
verkaufen können die Gemüsefüllung ist
auf ein Minimum reduziert mit der
standardisierten Produktion und den
billigen Löhnen in Asien lässt sich mit
dem teigtrick richtig Geld machen
60 tiefgefrorene Rollen verkauft der
Großhändler Metro für 5,44 € macht pro
einzelne Rolle nur 9 Cent eine Portion
Frühlingsrollen kostet im Restaurant
meist 3,90 €
[Musik]
über 700 Prozent mehr als der
Einkaufspreis
[Musik]
viele Tiefkühlprodukte enthalten
Glutamat diese 10 taufrühlingsrollen
nutzen den Geschmacksverstärker der
stimuliert den Appetit Gäste wollen
dadurch immer mehr essen
[Musik]
in Sebastian leges Restaurant landen die
fertigen Frühlingsrollen in der Friteuse
nach wenigen Minuten ist die Vorspeise
fertig und er kann im Handumdrehen seine
Gäste verköstigen Krabbenchips und
Frühlingsrollen alle zubereitet von der
Lebensmittelindustrie euch jetzt
geschmeckt
Chinesen ja super lecker ja
wir sind offenbar längst an die
vorgefertigten Produkte gewöhnt die
Lebensmittelindustrie hat die
Restaurants erobert wenn ich im
Restaurant fertige Tiefkühlware anbiete
und dann zu einem deutlich höheren Preis
weiterverkaufe ist es natürlich super
lukrativ hier sollte ich mir als
Verbraucher wirklich überlegen muss ich
die im Restaurant bestellen